oh my god okay let's get to it
I need this sucker victory hello John
Prescott all right guys welcome I'm
trying to get this first victory this
solo victory and call of duty black ops
I am gonna keep doing this until I get a
damn victory on Griffin on you get some
water in me Oh
you think that's nice to say that about
somebody you know don't be rude in the
chat God because it just mean people
sometimes okay here we go we don't get
just a baby where you go get just uh you
go get just done there we go the chair
right there I like that okay whatever
I'm so used to being called Montez it's
like whatever at this point I might
change it to my middle name what's world
league play I don't even know what that
is
all right anyway let's go black out I
don't think he plays online
okay here we go here we go
sulla blackout here we go let's get that
Sun black out saw the background
no Clippers hat right so today's
strategy is I'm gonna be mad aggressive
today will be super aggressive I'm not
gonna just sit around and wait I'm going
for this [ __ ]
we're not gonna be camping we grab a
guns and we lookin for fools today I'm
on the Xbox y'all oh my god
more jokes about the nose and glasses I
mean Jesus
you think you original [ __ ] you
think you're original you know what you
got to get I should block you let
dumbass joke
yeah hmm just coming at me I feel like
someone's coming at you coming at me bro
oh [ __ ] people just firing me just good
I'll just leave you [ __ ] shoot yes ha
ha
headshot headshot punch to the face
terribly shooting I got to shoot at the
face let's get practice time
five all right where we going
let me see
there we go follow blaka I'll just drop
this just drop and I ain't even [ __ ]
around we're going for this [ __ ] right
away there's nothing over here where am
I going this way oh [ __ ] I'm not into oh
my god I'm already starting off bad oh
my God look at oh my god wait I gotta go
this way there's a truck right here
hopefully nobody's in here already right
in that window is there a gun yes yes
okay got a gun okay that's good
okay okay anybody over here no close
that [ __ ] okay cool
Oh two shotguns I don't want shotguns oh
my got to get another gun
god dammit this is what I'm talking
about right now people but the [ __ ] is
already firing their people where
where's the circle oh no we don't know
what a circle is yet sitrep potential
collapse detected relocation indicated
safe zone is advised oh my god where is
it oh I'm close I'm close to the circle
y'all sorry do I hear somebody oh [ __ ]
let me go to this camera real fast
okay give me this okay some healing okay
here's a better gun yes - give me this
[ __ ] okay I got to get a backpack now
some [ __ ] why are you already firing
it fools you here - [ __ ] oh my god but
it's so low do I even want to risk going
down boy I just said I was gonna be
aggressive okay let's go let's go let's
go let's go let's go let's go
all right slow down get some bushes
action look behind me I shouldn't
[ __ ] is tailing me alright we
don't do this right
alright boom I know somebody was down
there right you think oh I see somebody
right there you see that guy right there
oh [ __ ] okay there was somebody right
there I don't think anybody was in these
buildings you think [ __ ] it let's go
check
Oh somebody was close-quarters action
yeah somebody already [ __ ] wrecked
these rooms circle collapse imminent get
to safety
oh there's a thing right here shekel
grand I mean I'm not gonna grab that all
right come on
[ __ ] I came in ready to blast fools
I need to get some [ __ ] oh man
there's no way to just hasn't been
ransacked already this whole thing wait
make sure nobody's behind me why here
[ __ ] coming
oh my god this is nervous time y'all
here we go here we go here we go yo here
we go yo so what's in there we go
oh [ __ ] this whole area has already been
ransacked see that goddamn it do I even
want to go in this building oh man just
nothing over here for me oh [ __ ] dude oh
just come in ready to blast come in
ready to blast y'all oh [ __ ] you know
what I'm gonna go around this building
oh [ __ ] I hear somebody
oh my god well I'm looking I can't look
at the [ __ ] chat and look at the the
damn screen god [ __ ] you guys are
selfish okay I'm gonna try to move my
chat over a little so I can see it
better okay
goddamnit alright I'm looking at the
damn chat okay guys let me look at the
chat real fast
Jesus okay oh wait wait wait is anything
is anybody in there oh look at these
guns right here I gotta get this gun
real fast okay okay oh [ __ ] oh my god
this is so nervous time right now I need
to get out of this I need to get out of
this building oh [ __ ] they're outside
shooting
yes backpack see okay come on I'm almost
in the circle in the building though
okay let's go man this is [ __ ]
building as a [ __ ] what's going on
outside I don't even want to go outside
oh [ __ ] damn what no one is Oh should I
hear somebody oh [ __ ] somebody's coming
maybe I just throw some smoke out there
right
Oh check that out inside the bathroom
I'm still in the circle [ __ ] this I'm
throwing smoke all right there we go
let's go [ __ ] I'm in the panic zone
right now okay Shh anybody outside up in
this [ __ ]
why am i whispering like you
[ __ ] can hear what is that
Rockets oh I know [ __ ] rocket well
here's the thing
further collapse expected relocate to
safe zone wait let me see if somebody
comes in right here okay y'all all right
we are in the circle right now which is
good I wonder if anybody who's over
there there's anybody up top oh [ __ ]
just this nervous time there's anybody
up top here just looking at me being a
fool I don't think so
I just need some [ __ ] armor let there
be some armor in here goddamn it just no
farmer in this [ __ ] 45 County some 5 6
ok ok Gaul Supply Drop incoming
ok how far away am I oh [ __ ] I'm kind of
far
god damn it's 9 millimeter
5 6 there you go alright
goddamnit what do I do I'm gonna Lock
this door over here
get down
I'll hear some firing
okay oh [ __ ]
panic time
okay circle collapse imminent get to say
my god circle collapse in a minute
oh [ __ ] what the hell was that okay all
I need is five six dead silence
let's [ __ ] use that [ __ ] right now oh
I gotta go this [ __ ] circle was
coming on me right now
is it coming [ __ ] it's coming right now
- [ __ ] [ __ ] man
Oh dollar super check dollar thank you
dollar make them hollow place SM five
six
no what am i doing Griffin get out of
here is there anything in this [ __ ] five
sitting like I'm grabbing ammo as I'm
going here we go y'all
okay here we go [ __ ] I'm just running
without looking that's how you get
killed just how you get killed on these
streets only Street son okay here we go
I gotta come up on this [ __ ] slow
alright we bout to be in the circle
oh just 25 people left - I'm in the top
25 y'all top 25 let's get this win but I
don't have any armor oh man there's
gonna be nothing over here look at this
[ __ ] nobody's over there here comes the
thing right here but I'm in it okay
there's a truck right there what if I
should grab that truck and just say [ __ ]
it I know I got 0 kills this is [ __ ]
God how far away oh my god I'm mad far
you know what I'm getting this truck
[ __ ] it let's go see if we can find some
armor real fast Oh Daniel Armour in here
man Oh dogs gonna get lucky is that some
five six no what is this [ __ ]
oh my god dude I don't know I can't go
on the bridge oh [ __ ] what was that get
ready to blast I'm coming in two rooms
but here we go
yes yes somebody left me some armor son
where's that coming from
you know what [ __ ] it I'm gonna grab
this truck oh my god I know I should
cross the river you right if I take this
truck when we look at the map if if I if
I Drive the truck around River town oh
no [ __ ] it we're going to be doing truck
oh my god is as dangerous as [ __ ]
and born around and born around oh [ __ ]
somebody what the [ __ ] was that
Yesi here we go son
who the [ __ ] that somebody's out here
trying to sneak up on me oh [ __ ] just a
spooky time oh [ __ ] oh my god oh [ __ ]
it's gonna be in this thing oh my god
the circle oh [ __ ] here comes the thing
I hear some shooting I don't want him to
do imma throw this smoke bomb over there
okay there's 15 people left up in this
[ __ ] is this thing gonna get me oh it's
gonna get me oh [ __ ] oh my god oh my god
oh my god people let me see how I died
it's a [ __ ] kill get this is my look
at this camping ass piece of [ __ ] right
here man
ah that's a horrible way to die okay I
don't think I was aggressive enough
who's Brandon what's Brandon saying yeah
okay let's try it again
I want to get this I'm gonna keep doing
it till I get it
alright here we go
you know your rude comments about my
weight is how you gonna get blocked
okay here we go
well how come it's not what's going on
Oh solo searching is searching for solo
all right here we go
all right look at the chat for a sec
while I'm here
oh god guys your comments are so stupid
just stop we're gonna get this solo
victory we going for the soul of it we
going for the Sun of it to be
[Music]
okay here we go we go here we go yo this
game is so infuriating punch that fool
in the face what son what
back of the head hit back the head your
head was just chicken sighs okay
Wow I love this blue outfit oh [ __ ]
she's a shot me blackout blackout
that's funny
technology deficient dad society that's
a funny one
oh all right I'm gonna wait
I'm waiting Sun I'm waiting all right
here we go this nineteen people still in
the dropship all right here we go
I'm going to the [ __ ] lighthouse I'm
going to the lighthouse there's always
some good [ __ ] in there all right come
on come on hope I'm the only one going
to the lighthouse I think I am
oh [ __ ] does that mean they're zombies
there
oh this other [ __ ] at the
lighthouse - oh my god oh [ __ ] I just
hurt myself just [ __ ] zombies in this
[ __ ] and I don't have a gun oh my god
you know what I'm getting the [ __ ] out
of here hey I gotta get the [ __ ] out of
there
oh she got the dick in her mouth again I
can't leave I don't have a gun but I'm
in the circle okay so this is good
did I run by a gun let's see that oh god
she just feels like she'd just been
demolished
it's like demolished her throat okay
here we go here we go here we go we
gotta get in here and get a gun
yes give it to me son
okay nine milli okay I need another gun
though
well [ __ ] this is so and this is like oh
my god oh there's a helicopter I should
totally hit i'ma hit this copter
I will helicopter give me some [ __ ] 50
Cal yeah razor wire I don't need that
[ __ ] oh I get a machete No
backpack okay
all right is it what a double - no
should I get this so I could just you
know what circle collapsed a minute I'm
give these rockets mmm
check the zone I'm in the zone I don't
need the helicopter yet you know what
I'm gonna do is almost i'ma stay by the
helicopter that flight it is on when I
need to what do you think jack oh [ __ ] I
hear somebody
[Music]
[Music]
or I should like oh my god I don't know
what to do let's see if I see anybody
out here did I leave that door open I
think I did I probably shouldn't have oh
I hear somebody out here to the right we
open this one wait see I want to know if
that guy from the lighthouse is gonna
come over here I don't know what to do
I got armor I got I don't have enough 50
Cal though Tim that's not enough oh
you're right somebody said something
good where's that razor wire at where
was it oh [ __ ] it was in the other room
though
Oh was down here
forgot where it was oh [ __ ] this is
ridiculous
let's see if somebody's coming up here
swimming oh [ __ ]
oh god I'm telling you all the little
noises make me scared I don't know where
that raised here it is no no that's not
it I should grab this too though huh oh
[Music]
I hear somebody
somebody's upstairs
somebody is up the [ __ ] stairs god
damn it dude oh I hear him here we go
Supply Drop inbound
[ __ ] what should I do
oh my god sit at the desk shut up
oh I hear them over here get ready to
blast oh this is so [ __ ] infuriating
oh sheesh I hear somebody
oh [ __ ] further collapse expected travel
to indicate it safe zone oh come on
oh that is so annoying I'm gonna hit the
gate twice Jesus Christ man
that would've been so dope I wanted to
blast em fool oh [ __ ] look we're almost
in the circle anyway right here sir I
need to get a different gun right what's
this [ __ ] yeah I need to get rid of this
rocket launcher oh this one looks this
looks heavy duty as [ __ ] alright just
five six me that armor plating I need
that or should I get this gun I don't
know what's gonna bet er I think this 50
cows gonna be a beast how did I play my
injured
oh I blew myself up and that's some
[ __ ] right there y'all
I mean I even go over to oh my god I'm
so out in the open you saw a boat where
no I can't get no [ __ ] boat let me go
in here where am i right now come into
circle circle collapse imminent this
building you know what [ __ ] it let's
just go we gonna stay around the circle
area why didn't my god I wanted to blow
that guy up so bad that is so [ __ ]
stupid okay okay let's take a look
around
see if [ __ ] are around
here we go I even try to go in here well
somebody was already up here oh this is
like a good spot Oh huh
see fools coming you know can't see [ __ ]
oh my god I just scared myself I did not
mean to hit that glass there's a guy
right there oh [ __ ] I see him you see
you got Derek oh man where is he oh he's
like a [ __ ] hidden Oh may I try to go
after this fool
good to see we can sneak up on this fool
I know I saw him over here where'd he go
oh sure the collapse expected relocated
to safe zone go on in the circle - he's
got to come to me what's in here this is
bath just toilet dirty no damn it why am
i making noise okay okay Oh God oh this
is so refuting all right
see I'm thinking that people are gonna
be coming from here you know what I mean
to try to get to the circle they got to
pass me
while this gun sucks oh god guys I I
don't I don't know what guns are good
you know I mean Oh
oh [ __ ] I'm like knee-deep in the circle
oh my god
get to safety I mean these are
[ __ ] from down here got to come
up here to me oh I wonder if I should
get into grass [ __ ]
oh man just 26 people left all I am
knee-deep in the circle right now oh my
god see people got to come to me I got
the high ground I'm like I'm like oh
[ __ ]
I know I got to get in Rambo mode I wish
I had some mud I could put on myself
just one eye you know what I mean
remember Rambo I just got to go slow oh
[ __ ] I hope nobody's coming from behind
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was that well that
was me
we're two [ __ ] this guy at [ __ ] God
man why didn't I kill that [ __ ] I don't
want to be in the same spot when he
comes back oh my god dude the advice
further collapse expected relocate to
safe zone while he's trying to come back
around
this gun sucks you're so right
I don't have nothing I don't got no
grenades nothing I got a book it I'm
headed to this [ __ ] house right here
[ __ ]
sitrep circle collapse imminent get to
safety
oh my god I can't do I need to get on
that no
[Music]
oh my god this is this is how is there
18 people left in this little last
circle come on get some ammo in this ant
oh my God look how long this ammo takes
oh Jesus Christ I'm all loaded up let's
go oh my God look at the little circle
I'm sweating and [ __ ] nobody's in here
[ __ ] oh you know what I should do I
should going here okay we gonna camp
[Laughter]
okay whoo let's take a second y'all
let's take it down to like five six
people then we gonna come out blasting
uh did I kill that dude I didn't even
know I killed him oh [ __ ] I did get a
kill
alright y'all we're gonna let them fight
it out and then we gonna go out it blast
for the wind oh [ __ ] wait wait wait oh I
gotta put my scar on
oh that's perfect right whoo oh my god
this is like I'm so nervous right now
yeah I don't know I'm [ __ ] sweating
in here I gotta get this gamer go on oh
[ __ ] is like 12 people left 12 people
left okay oh I'm right there I'm gonna
wait I'm away to the last [ __ ] second
let me see something
oh I don't have any okay I only have
four heels we don't let these [ __ ]
kill each other this is Rambo style
right here are we got 10 seconds okay
all right just okay this circle is gonna
come in quick oh my god you hear all
that we coming out blaster here comes
the circle somebody open this door kills
me I swear to god my circles coming in
y'all it's down to ten oh my god here we
go y'all it's down to nine okay okay
okay okay wait for it wait for it it's
coming wait for it
oh my god okay I got to go here it is
okay all right here we go
[ __ ]
jump out this window [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
somebody's on me okay eighth place
started at 15 let me see the killcam I
got see the killcam it comes a killcam
look at me I mean oh he was right there
god damn it look at me jumping like a
idiot oh he was right there I should
have turned a corner I blasted him that
was terrible that was terrible
okay one more one more one more one more
because I did 15th place 8th I know I
slid right into death that was a deaf
slot it was terrible
but I got a kill though good for me I
don't even know I killed that dude [ __ ]
so I did better 15 place now did a place
with a kill okay so y'all seeing the
progress so don't hate probably check my
phone real fast
what error okay what's going on you have
too many people in your party to enter
this game what was in my party wait what
the [ __ ] going on man who's trying to
know dude how do you get people out of
your [ __ ]
oh hey [ __ ] I didn't ask you to
be in my thing okay uh how do you get
rid of people guys how do you get
how the [ __ ] do you get out of here [ __ ]
that annoys me when people do that you
can't just [ __ ] join my game [ __ ] you
I do not like it look like a footlocker
manager [ __ ] y'all
wait let me see all rightie ways all
right guys
15th place 8th place we see in the
progress seeing the progress baby baby
bear baby bear baby let me check the
twitch chat i might not supposed to be
on twitch and twitter at the same time
but [ __ ] it equal opportunists up in
here son there's only 7 people on twitch
anyway so y'all and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
well there you go like a look at the
twitch chat and a YouTube channel - same
time oh [ __ ]
with that five dollars yeah
don't insult [ __ ] - $5 things good for
y'all thank you I appreciate it you know
what I'm saying all this money is going
to make the podcast better - by the way
I'm just gonna get like better cameras
get all the [ __ ] hooked up get my game
on right so I appreciate it no I got but
I got both chats up if you want which I
can see both chats all right here we go
all right what do y'all think I think I
wasn't I wasn't I was aggressive but not
aggressive it's all about being in a
circle early for me so here we go
let's do this
see they dropping out too fast I don't
want to do that know what I know what
I'm gonna do I'm going way well
everybody's going to the boat watch but
I'm gonna go way over here you know what
I mean
look at that [ __ ] right there
he's already over there here we go
oh [ __ ] my housekeepers [ __ ] vacuum
in my [ __ ] do you know I'm I'm trying
to kill people you out you're vacuuming
oh my god you run so slow in this game
compared to apex if you're used to
playing apex this [ __ ] feels slow as
[ __ ]
well there's a truck right there -
alright alright we got this we got this
I just need to get a gun right away let
me get a gun let me get a gun
oh [ __ ] when he does he'll [ __ ] it you
know what there's always guns at the gas
station I think I'm the only one over
here - there's a truck all right we got
this we got this oh [ __ ]
oh come on there's always guns where the
guns at where the guns at [ __ ] aren't
there guns in his [ __ ] gas
stations when there's always guns in
this [ __ ] gas - Dom so infuriated
right now y'all I do I see a gun here's
a gun okay what kind of 40 cat 45 cow um
is this even a good gun okay get that
scope can't get to time scope I don't
know if I should get to three times go
here's another gun alright I'm all
[ __ ] and there's like two guns hey
Johnny seven six I don't need seven six
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
what's in here what's in here give me
this what's that medic okay I'll take
that what's this [ __ ] 38 I don't need
that oh my god I don't even have enough
12-gauge wait what's this [ __ ] was this
the same building yeah it is okay what
do I do now where are we
oh [ __ ] I'm far as [ __ ] I'm getting in
this truck how much time I got 45
seconds oh [ __ ] yeah I'm getting in the
truck [ __ ] it let's go across the lands
Superman oh my god I'm so far away
there we go there we go
like circle collapsed a minute get to
safety you know what I'm going in this
house I'm going in this house y'all
[ __ ] I got time yes
give me that level to see oh [ __ ]
give me this I'll take that oh my god
why should I go upstairs real fast
oh [ __ ] is anything up here oh my god
there's nothing up here
give me a backpack real fast and we that
backpack real fast 7/6 what I need oh
god I need 45 oh my god okay give me
that you know what let's get out of here
where my truck at where's my truck oh
[ __ ] I lost my truck there it is
okay that was a good start I'm saying
oh [ __ ] I can't drive
I'm gonna go knee deep into the circle
I'm not even gonna [ __ ] waste time
wait OSHA's so much shoot me
[ __ ] this watch this I'm taking the
truck all the way in okay okay what is
this I mean that's a drop incoming seven
six twenty seven six ninety forty I need
to get a different gun
I don't even know if this is a good gun
y'all even know if this is a good gun oh
[ __ ] I need to stop [ __ ] around
nope
outlaws I get this outlaw oh my god but
what is this
oh [ __ ] give me all this why do I jump
god damn it
these pork chips
um check it this gun instead of the one
I have I don't even know [ __ ] it I was
gonna keep the gun I have where are we
oh [ __ ] I'm in the circle I'm like right
there
oh I hear somebody
oh my god okay so somebody was already
here okay oh [ __ ] you hear that wait the
C 12-gauge
9-millimeter I don't got any ammo for
this stupid gun I have oh [ __ ] I need to
go get that oh but I don't have a
partner to fire the gun so I go get that
oh here we go here we go I got two chips
I did get two chips I hear I hear a
helicopter further collapse expected
travel to indicate it's safe zone oh she
just a stupid gun I'm using I need to go
get this vehicle right here right now
I'm trying to get some head shots up in
here while they're shooting over here
this way we see if I could see Dee's
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] hold your breath
girl oh [ __ ] I see anybody how far
away's did though it's not even that far
oh [ __ ] I hear shots but I don't see
where they are
come on let me just get one guy in my
sights that'd be so dope
I mean I hear shootin but I don't see
nobody this is so frustrating
I should camp on this thing if I see
somebody go for it
tag I sit Rep Circle collapse imminent
get off [ __ ] let's go
ah damn I forgot tried to shoot me but
you missed full yes
[Music]
you're a helicopter up in this [ __ ] all
fun I can't do that
oh [ __ ] what happened
I think somebody hit me with a rocket
that was I don't know what the [ __ ] just
happened but I got to see the killcam
what the [ __ ] just happened oh this guy
was chasing me
oh he threw a [ __ ] grenade oh that's
that's infuriating that's that's I mean
that's so stupid
like what a stupid way to die you know
what I mean what do you think twitch Oh
God
oh my god that is alright I'm gonna get
this win alright that was a little
setback
all right here we go one more
all right
okay here we go y'all deploy yes hello
everyone
okay I'm back I'm back to the chat I'm
looking at the chat what's up y'all
hello chat I'm trying to engage man oh
my god okay all right so from the chat
I'm seeing I need to loop more I need to
loop more what else engage more you know
hello Daniel Constantine eeny Meeny
whatever the [ __ ] your name is
I know I know okay so I got a loop more
be more aggressive get into Rambo mode
pick up all the ammo um
don't stand too much and oh I need to
read you a five-dollar message I didn't
see it
here we go to grab attachments right I
need to grab the attachments got it
okay let me look at see any more I don't
have any more chance I don't see you
know they should put all the chat good
chats like there all right I got it
and do a 5-minute set while I play
[ __ ] stupid hey what's up y'all it's
gonna be here it's gonna be here call of
duty don't you hate when your attachment
ain't a right attachment when you drop
down are you punching people and nothing
happens to them and I'm like oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] to the face the face wash your face
white boy your face is dirty not just
hit look at this dude what the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ] martian guy straight hate
crime I know
fight back white boy fight back all
right where we going
the mission area classify the mission
area
okay everybody drops their nope nope
nope nope son nope not doing that nope
nope not going there nope not going
there not going there
nope people still in the ship twenty
seven twenty five twenty two twenty
nineteen eighteen here we go drop in oh
I got that good okay all right here we
go 70 miles an hour there it is oh my
gosh somebody's going to the same place
I'm going now you know what we're going
right here here we go here we go get a
gun get a gun get a gun there's no guns
oh my god where the [ __ ] of guns
there's no [ __ ] guns over here man
here we go here we go
yes ah [ __ ] whatever that is I'm
getting it getting it mess mine yes
uh-huh oh I like that mesh mine actually
potential collapse detected okay now let
me go over here see what the [ __ ] we got
over here okay Oh give me this kit
goddamn it
what is this I need five six I need some
five six what is this gun don't have a
second gun oh Sh I get dis or should I
keep tip I'm gonna keep this gun
actually I'm gonna keep this just a
little peashooter
I forgot to grab the ammo you right
don't break windows I got a break
windows y'all I gotta get in here what
is this oh [ __ ] I need a debt last game
that 3/8 ammo wait give me give this
[ __ ] give me just give me this
ok how to flick you out of this room get
ready to blast fools
okay oh [ __ ] I gotta grab this gun
I gotta grab it level two yes level two
ha come on
Oh somebody's in here backpack [ __ ]
feel it
wait close the door okay what is this
[ __ ]
take that 45 cow on me five six goddamn
it so kill collapse a minute get to
safety
so I just pick this up anyway
five six okay where are we okay I'm
close is the [ __ ] closing I got time
right all right [ __ ] oh [ __ ] somebody's
over there
[ __ ] man Ron Griffin run for us give it
oh my god all right okay I'm ready to
play with some people one last game and
I'll play with some people so here's how
it's gonna work
you know so you better join now Eric
Griffin first forced three to join and
we out and I'm some I'm leaving
I was terrible way to die
alright alright that guys in I need one
one more and we ready to go let's go
one more are we ready to go meet
something plug my mic in
all right hello hello hello there we go
all right there it is there we go
deploy yo all right this is it guys we
got to get this win
okay okay man I tried so hard it was
like I finished eighth on that one but
that was whack
here we go we're gonna do a little quads
little quads with the boys little quad
so who's all in here Oh got it [ __ ] so
loud Jesus Christ oh my god yeah it
might start a party do a party quick
actually do a party make it private
hold up I don't want a bunch of people
coming in listen to know that annoys me
they did herbs okay okay boom there you
go
make you private though you know I mean
make your party private all right I got
ya send those guys they invite whoever
they are all right here we go guys here
we go yeah here we go yo well if I can
get this quad win it'll still be my
first victory I do not have a Call of
Duty victory
I'll be your first let's do it what's
that other guy's name weapon weapon axe
oh yeah yeah yeah but with an X for the
oh oh yeah it's Weapon X yeah P X and X
yeah shut up with your pizza comments
and your like stupid you see a picture
of you at least I'm out here I'm out
here in these streets on camera bring
your ass on camera let me see how fat
you are
where we going nowhere we landed
lighthouse lighthouse lighthouse by
house okay lighthouse cuz I know how to
get dere let's go let's go now
we go oh [ __ ] watch me not make it to
the light I'm not gonna make it look at
this [ __ ]
where are you gonna make it - oh god
here we go
no we can make it like right outside the
lighthouse we can make you we can make
it yeah I'm gonna make it I'm making it
to the I'm making it I'm making it to
the lighthouse look at that oh ah see
that made it got a gun already ah okay
here we go
got two guns up in this [ __ ] pistol I
said the lighthouse be mad at me that I
made it and you could this all this
backpacks there's so much [ __ ] in the
like oh [ __ ] does fire [ __ ] in here I
gotta get it better gun I don't like
this [ __ ] I don't like I don't like
shotguns I'm just not nothing I'm good
with any gun but this shotgun is like
really sharp especially [ __ ] it's so
dark here we go there's a LMG out here
you want that look I got like I hate
when people do that go get those such
and such I don't know what's a [ __ ]
you're talking about
I went kind of far away but I'm coming
coming back okay yo air armor down here
you got armor yeah needs armor Ajax you
need armor yeah I got some over here
the lighthouse hello how you doing I'm
good man what's happening you know what
can you give me like 30 minutes all
right cool thank you all right yeah yeah
call me back call me back there thank
you
all right but sorry guys sorry I saw
that call right on stream stream and
call I wish I could this is I see are
better than a what's other gun I have
what does e zu longer or whatever yeah
it's nice yours better Ajax there's an
extended mags or anything if you need it
because that uh yeah yeah all right
let's do it
and we're right in a circle practically
here Eric I got a sight for you for your
eye CR right here oh gee oh that oh nice
wait are we gonna smell what are we
gonna do the rods are we just gonna walk
around we're gonna run around
I'm going after Wagga if we go this way
we can get into the circle yeah yeah
yeah yeah I agree
in the circle we should probably meet
back up yeah you want to come down this
way like towards the circle yeah let's
do this
those buildings are in our other three
buildings in the circle before the
bridge okay
yeah the YouTube chat is just really
annoying well you here I'll take that
twitch chat is more go ahead guys I'm
getting the potato chips other poker
chips got pork chips no some these
windows are broken yeah yeah yeah the
cuffs lorem running this is Kelvin the
garage door have you guys did you guys
wanna check the gas station I'm in the
circle yeah
keep we're in the circle so you don't
gotta like rush need to find that
[ __ ] f4 what about these buildings in
the back oh those are that's what we hit
we hit those ones that like South 195 we
can go hit these ones for the east 127
right yeah yeah yes
oh my god okay what is this for castle
any anima hi know the Spitfire here
anymore like you crazy when you play
apex then you play this you forget that
Friendly Fires on in this game yeah big
different I've already shot a friend
[Laughter]
[Music]
what does the paint can do what is that
for all the surface memos on your gun
yeah you get that backpack no I didn't
get it back why do I have a backpack
yeah I think I have a backpack you okay
we're Nikita wearing this Griffin do you
still need not let me see I I need five
six and I need 9-millimeter yeah but I
got a hundred of nine-millimeter I think
I'm okay there we go there you go here's
here's two hundred a mouthful I'm all
full I'm all full now 200 200 let's go
got an allocation oh there's a truck at
the gas station we want to do that it's
crazy that all these people in the game
we haven't seen anybody yet I never
understand that
we landed continental skirts it's a red
a red dot and hollow out you smash
windows
yeah we can either swim when the circle
closes or we can cross the bridge right
so why do we want to risk the bridge
well if we take the trash out the truck
is risky yeah shifting mesh mines on the
bridge you can get always run into those
mines let's just swim [ __ ] it do it yeah
this is a building right there keep on
swimming keep on swimming collapse
enemies where's the next okay we're in
the circle to knee deep I'll go to these
buildings right ahead of us
are the ones ahead of us which one 350 I
don't see any broken windows almost any
open doors this garage is open there's a
oh yeah this they've been in here you've
been in here oh yeah this place has been
ransacked
oh yeah same over here by the bakery
they already had a backpack all right
silence are up here on this road I
dropped a 50 Cal if any well somebody
somebody came in on one of these things
Oh God yeah this whole area is a useless
what about this what about these
buildings back here like 117 those were
all hit oh yeah you're right yeah they
are you already went to the pizzeria
somebody did oh this buildings for sale
for sale by the owner - I wonder what
the lease is hey that number down
there's people over there I suppose
I'm like apex and should cut that sniper
oh you got one yeah I got it I got it
are they are they across the bridge or
they are always on the roof I see em I
see them storm - they're gonna be
crossing the water I don't know about a
proteins or they were fight I killed
that guy but I definitely shot is that
yep you just got there's still someone
shooting right oh yeah Oh what is this
guy we got to go huh what are we gonna
do
and still another was up on the roof
green bro he's on the roof I just can't
ping in this game dude no neven aid but
I can't really get that close in case
somebody doesn't have it yet
oh he's he went up the ladder he's
laying down behind I just got in that
from 190 with paranoia on so they could
be across you guys want to or do you
want to go god
there's odds is back this whole area
over here behind just to those like that
with a deck construction yard I got shot
a bunch and that uh yeah there's all
this up 1:30 let me just throw smoke
always bond that trees behind that tree
whose tree and behind the rock i watch i
watch all right hit him
my god thank them carefully Jax I think
one moved up on us to the right over
here I'm watching the right I'm gonna
get back you'll you through that smoke
there we go
how the storm is coming we should
probably just get us back up this barrel
barrel just run up this hill here oh
there's a truck over here but let's see
how far are we yeah and get by without
and you all want to take it or not I
think we can get there without it clear
little space between us in these guys
that's true people behind it all right
I'm coming do not take it all the way
into the circle thank you for that
dollar wherever that was sorry that I
didn't see someone in the middle of
playing here
I'll check I'll stay so how looks out
stay south
yep Seoul must be at that cabin South
he's running all those people right
ahead of us you see them dropped out
honey on me oh my god level 3 field oh
[ __ ] there's a guy to 93 Eric he's
running around the trees behind you oh
my god oh man I was busy running around
the smoke aw see him right here by me
nice to me there's way too many yeah we
get it we win until each but that's what
happens when you get into the truck you
get into the truck and everybody's like
they're right there get him okay I can
do one more and then I got to get off I
should have just been blasting but then
you don't want to shoot your own people
because I couldn't tell there was so
many people there that I was like oh my
god you know to me and the smoke was
there it was like too much I know I was
busy injecting myself a place all right
but I did a place by myself you know you
[ __ ] are supposed to help me get wins
you know they're mean I could do aids
without you
apex and apex is [ __ ]
wasted a grenade and their [ __ ]
confession that last oh did I start it
Oh searching here we go
let's do this
all right let's get a plan where are we
going before it's too late
and even they're gonna guess it depends
how safe you want to be be like this is
kind of far away but what about her here
I marked it let's get some little houses
not yeah I don't think anyone would be
there next to turbine all right let's do
it let's do it
they added like six houses to that area
eight houses today let's go yeah there's
there's a good amount of stuff there now
black out
he's running school good to drop now no
there's a wait wait wait a little bit
yeah probably make it a feedback right
away
just pull up real early make sure you
have enough height which hopefully I do
it looks like I might all right there's
a couple a couple of houses south of it
you can go I'm right yeah I'm right
behind weapon
I'm liking bond we're going to the gas
station I'm ready
you're yeah we could drive a truck up to
you there's one here
let's get a gun first there's no gun for
me I'm just gonna haul ass over to you
oh there's like one little hood over
here taking all the good [ __ ] yo Griffin
over here these buildings are empty
I'm coming are you see what they're I
across the street oh gosh the street Oh
got you got you
let's see there's a backpack on the
second floor and a shotgun
I'm coming I got a shotgun already how
much I've done why kind of like shotguns
[ __ ] you know try it I don't like them
either but some gun just landed at that
way through Mart and there's people
there Weiss you've seen a second floor
alright I guess it's good we didn't land
there yeah [ __ ] building over here with
my hair for the back fact we can get in
this truck and come over there you know
yeah let's do that let's do that yeah
I'm a nice ER now I have two shotguns
like [ __ ] homeless are you all coming
over here should we go over there uh
it's up to you guys you know you can't
get into the passenger seat that's
stupid
it is stupid I'm just gonna hop in the
gym did drive the truck over
you know kids like ham
how am I supposed to pull a que turn on
this bridge this is bad god are we going
to this tunnel
no I'm backing up going back the
building when I were the buildings to
our right the gun no I don't I can drop
you at the I have a G K s and give you
hopefully no one's down here
I'll be careful
I don't think there's anyone here this
bloob had gone out homes have gone up
top that building that buildings been
broke in that garage in the middle the
trauma kits usually spawn there's a gun
over here knows Damon Hey okay I'm back
I'm back I'm back I'm back in here
focused all right somebody was texting
me I had to take it [ __ ]
there's a gun on the top yeah I got a
Maddox I got a magic sorry them there's
a backpack somebody went into this
building here okay
where Oh somebody's been in here here's
this dumb bridge it's right here where
is he okay did you get even have nothing
really seven six two first-aid anyone
need a sniper scopes [ __ ] here you
can behind us I have a gun I got it
there we go you're good yeah this is
good I want a shotgun just got ammo for
it for this oh this is for five ammo -
that's not very good
Damon's for five none of us have armor
are we gonna like try to hit this going
to river pounding good go across yeah
maybe we should just go across we can go
across like just no letter
I'm gonna call the flag and move it down
the street it's like a little island
right here some ploy dropping coming
there definitely fighting over there
[Music]
don't split up too much here I'm on the
top of the bridge scouting ok does every
one of these buildings were attitude hmm
yeah all that looted I will go up to the
right here up to the trailer park and
the gas station see if there's anything
gas stations hit well the doors are open
tear the park to its trailer all these
trailers all this [ __ ] is hit damn it I
hear a car I'm not here car over by the
silos oh I see it moving to 40 South
engineer I'm not gonna shoot he's coming
across the bridge should we do should we
he looks so low just be careful just one
sixty bro he's he's trying to flank over
there the other team was shooting at him
you know they're up on the building look
out look out ajax up on the building at
220 he was a top brick building next to
the church yo there's people 295 and at
the oh my god this is a nightmare we can
always back up over here to the trailer
park
yeah come back over here towards the
trailer park that way we're not getting
surrounded as people are trying to cross
to from the farm Retreat retreat now we
all gotta go this oh [ __ ] I'm getting
shot come back to trailer I got your
back on the wall here I don't see him
all right Oh should I keep shining okay
he's that one nine yet
yeah 190 I'm uh put some shots at him
can you give him up I don't see many
more do you got him on okay they're all
gonna be coming now drop him back a
little bit they have to come to us dude
we should just say one thing I hit 160
at the brick building at 160 look out
might be coming up the left side
remember we still don't even have armor
so if you get shot a little bit true oh
wow where'd you get sniped Oh like like
100 probably gonna get one guys they're
running up to your lunch ah no I'm
nading on a ting oh [ __ ] oh I have no
more healing I have no healing we didn't
have armor well you don't have any armor
you go down so fast it's like no man all
right though that was fun well that's it
I'm done I gotta go
Griffin go back over thank you for
playing guys thank you for listening and
I'll be catch you on the flip side all
right thank you guys yep well that's it
y'all uh YouTube twitch thank you I
didn't get my first win but I did finish
eighth twice and I got a couple of kills
so maybe tomorrow or the next day we
will try to get that victory solo black
ops I'm looking at the wrong family
computer when I should be looking here
- eight-faced finishes - kills solo
Griffin governing will get it though
thanks guys peace